well circa celebrating its grand opening
today it's the first adults-only casino
resort in las vegas and now the tallest
north of the strip of course we were
there when the casino opened back in
october but the hotel officially opened
today
our hector mejia got the great
assignment of checking out one of the
brand new hotel rooms
we are on the 25th floor this is a king
corner room we have the seating area
here and really panoramic views of the
entire valley
from the mountain ranges off to the
views of downtown
look at this and right below we have
stadium swim
sports here a huge theme at circa and
they have a lot of neat features one
thing you will not
find is a telephone and that is because
this tablet
replaces the traditional telephone you
can actually make a phone call with this
tablet
another neat feature is the lighting you
can actually select the type of mood you
want from
candlelight to uh let's say let's try
happy hour a little bit more dim or if
you want to brighten things up you just
click
the bright button this whole project has
a reported price tag
of one billion dollars the artwork
around circa pays tribute to las vegas
golden era
and just like the casino floor the
design in the rooms reflects different
eras
something new mixed with shapes forms
and colors that were popular in
different era such as
the 20s 50s the 80s and the very first
guests had the chance to check in early
on saturday in what was called
the world's earliest check-in with
people checking in two days early for
free
the property created around fifteen
hundred jobs at a time when other places
are cutting back because of the pandemic
with the hotel tower opening today it
finalizes the phased
opening of circa it was a great
thing for just with how everything is in
the world right now that we were able to
phase the openings so that
having the casino open it kind of gave
us a couple months to really
kind of work things out and and kind of
get our feet underneath us and now with
opening the hotel um obviously is a huge
thing for downtown las vegas and las
vegas in general
the hotel tower is the tallest north of
the las vegas strip with 60 floors
it'll have 777 rooms
the property already has the title for
having the world's
largest sports book and it's hard to
believe construction for this began in
february of 2019 and here's another neat
thing
a lot of the artwork you'll find in the
rooms was designed
by local artists reporting from the
brand new circa resort hector mejia
8 news now it's a beautiful building
hector thanks